a mummy in my hotel room
just like five minutes of it i miss when
action movies had like really slapstick
[ __ ] like that
like there's there's a scene in the
mummy where
uh i forget the main actress's name but
uh she's like the female lead
and she's a librarian and she's like
doing like this weird like thing on
stilts on a ladder because she like gets
off balance
and then she loses balance and does a
domino effect of like all the bookcases
i'm like how does that
what the [ __ ] does that have to do with
this entire movie
and it was like you know when it was
shot i mean the vfx looks so expensive
for that shot and i'm like
who cares yeah i'm like oh there's like
still that era of filmmaking the goofy
[ __ ] yeah
so that's brendan fraser right
have you seen his before and after
yeah he looks way better now way better
yeah yeah my boy looking healthy
i i watched that
that movie he was in with don cheadle
and oh is that the one where he like
looked up the reason why he looked like
that yeah
it was like was it good
it was pretty good i think the
exposition wasn't that clear it was
basically about how like the mob was
like
manipulating
um
car manufacturing like safety policies i
am in the middle of watching this new
movie the last duel
with [ __ ] matt damon
uh ben affleck and adam driver okay and
it's a story of like these two
you know like
squires we know something about that
mm-hmm you know a little something about
being a square
we certainly do you know basically
serving uh this lord and like
how their lives
go and
it comes to a head because basically
matt damon's wife claims that the
adam driver's character assaulted her
okay um
i'm halfway through
it it's a crazy ass movie um
it
uh what the [ __ ] but the craziest part
about it is ben affleck can you can you
look this up
the third one yeah wait what that's ben
affleck yeah
go to the one
right there where he's looking like a
[ __ ] hype house kid
well he also looks like guy fieri who
got mugatu or whatever
from
dude and that's how he acts how the [ __ ]
did i not think of that that is that is
his character he's this drunken
[ __ ]
having orgies all the
time man
i'm not done with it yet but
you know because the way the movie's
structured is
it's in chapters and it's the truth
according to each character i actually
did feel bad tapping out but it was like
two in the morning so yeah that's fair
i'm excited to finish that movie though
i do feel like the film is just
one big like
what if adam driver was in game of
thrones yeah
i i did you know he's great isn't he
he's good
he's a good actor [ __ ] got ripped for
this movie did he yeah he's also in the
gucci one isn't he house of gucci have
you seen that i want to see that yeah
um did you see the
did you see seth rogan's
santa thing headlines about it no it's
the lowest rated show ever on imdb ooh
why
i don't know he said it's because of
they pissed off white supremacists
that's that was his
tweet basically got it um but i guess
like uh i don't know it might have been
that
people that watched like stephen crowder
were really mad about how like left this
it was so they like went and review
bombed it oh got it because it's
probably not the worst show in the
entire world but um
yeah
yeah the trailer yeah i don't know
it definitely doesn't look that great
animated christmas [ __ ] i just can't
care
yeah
personally i just i find that format to
be like even when i'd be in like
daycares like an elementary school and
they play like that [ __ ] claymation
rudolph santa movie i would just like oh
i loved that movie i [ __ ] what
loathed that why
i couldn't give a [ __ ] that was the [ __ ]
oh my god that like brings back just
this crazy feeling of nostalgia that
movie
i was rude like
who did that movie who did that movie
rankin bass oh never mind i thought i
was going to recognize the name are they
going to be like ranking that's more
like it that [ __ ] stunk
yeah nah nah that was a classic i gave
that um
period
uh series [ __ ] wheel of time a shot
on amazon
[Music]
luke uh i hope you don't like that show
cause i'm about to be mean to it that's
fine go for it
do you say period piece i guess it
actually it's not appear because so
basically it's based on some books that
are written around the time of like fire
and ice or whatever that like
that inspired lord um that inspired game
of thrones okay so this is jeff
this is jeffy trying to have his own
game
yeah jeffy
so they took
what is a [ __ ] 14 novel series okay
with a prequel
written by two different authors because
the guy who originally started it
[ __ ] died oh yeah i know you had to
come in and the series contains
something like 2 800 named characters in
the books oh wow and they're all like
point of view characters i guess so i
assume that means i know [ __ ] about
writing but i assume that's like you're
getting like little profiles of all
these different people it's like the
basic premise of the show is that
there's like magic it's like the force
basically and only women can have it
because if men get it try to [ __ ] with
it they go crazy okay um and i guess
they're like on the search for like neo
like this neo type character was like
the one like the return of like the
ultimate evil like i don't know dragon
something uh dragging these balls nice
yeah
and uh
[Laughter]
that for a show with so much money they
like fl they shot it all in the czech
republic so it's like very clearly
expensive
the direct i don't know if is the actors
the directing i assume the directing
holy [ __ ]
i've not seen acting that awful
really they should have hired like us
five years ago if they were aiming that
low on performance
it is [ __ ] bad
i couldn't
and so i think it's a directing because
the fact that every actor does that and
they do weird [ __ ] where it goes like 24
frames to 60.
and like you don't even know what the
story is it just starts with the gone
girl lady putting on like some robe okay
she's like
there's magic and it's bad and we have
to stop the dragon and then that's all
you get you're like what the [ __ ]
what i even just watch
and then you just see some lady like
kill a dude and she's like
you see what happens when you mess with
it you make it filthy i'm like this
feels like porn
you're like okay yeah i'm like all right
all right
change the scene on me i'm like nasty
yeah they did have a horny ass scene
like right out the gate though amazon's
figuring out how to be hbo okay like 10
minutes in they have the gone girl lady
in a hot tub yeah you know
and i see i stuck around
[Laughter]
sucks acting so
oh you know what maybe
let's take it out for a little bit you
know but then a guy came in the scene
and you see his naked ass
and i was like no
you're gonna make it filthy
you're hurting her
and then you know then he slides into
the tub and she uses like her witch
powers to make like the water hot
because he's like it could be warmer
and she's like it's fine he's like it
could be warmer she's like
i was like okay
okay and then do they bang or what no
then like some guy comes in the scene
and starts talking he doesn't come in
the scene but you know
he like changed scenes this dude is just
talking like ugh oh yeah gross nah i
just bailed because
it just feels like one of those bad
movies where they're like there's a big
danger ahead there is
and it cuts to some other people did you
hear about the big danger ahead i did
you're like all right
i guess there's big danger
this is bad